foreign
[Applause]
that might not come as a surprise to
some of you I look like a woman
I'm dressed like one I guess
the thing is I also have balls
and it does take a lot of nerve to come
up here and talk to you about my
genitalia hello uh but I'm not talking
about bravery or courage I mean
literally I have balls
right here
right where a lot of you have ovaries
I'm not male or female I'm intersexed
most people assume that you're
biologically either a man or a woman but
it's actually a lot more complex than
that
there's so many ways somebody could be
intersex and in my case it means I was
born with XY chromosomes which you
probably know as male chromosomes and I
was born with a vagina and balls inside
my body
I don't respond to testosterone so
during puberty I grew breasts but I
never got acne or body hair body oil you
can be jealous of that
um
but even though I don't actually have a
uterus I was born without one so I don't
menstruate I can't have biological
children
we put people in boxes based on their
genitalia before a baby's even born we
ask whether it's a boy or a girl as if
it actually matters
as if you're going to be less excited
about having a baby if it doesn't have
the genitals you wanted
as if what's between somebody's legs
tells you anything about that person
are they kind generous
funny
smart
who do they want to be when they grow up
genitals don't actually tell you
anything yet we Define ourselves by them
in this Society we love putting people
into boxes and labeling each other it
kind of it gives us a sense of belonging
and knows teaches us kind of how to
interact with one another but there's
one really big problem and biological
sex is not black or white
it's on a spectrum
besides your genitalia you also have
your chromosomes your gonads like
ovaries or testicles you have your
internal sex organs your hormone
production your hormone response and
your secondary sex characteristics like
breast development body Hair Etc
those seven areas of biological sex all
have so much variation yet we only get
two options male or female
which is kind of absurd to me because I
can't think of a single other human
trait but there's only two options for
skin color hair height eyes you can
either have nose a or nose B that's it
no other options
if there are infinite ways for our
bodies to look my mind's to think
personalities to act
when it makes sense that there's that
much Variety in biological sex too
did you know that besides XX or XY
chromosomes you could have x x and x Y
chromosomes or you could have an extra x
x y or two extra x x x y goes on from
there and for those normal people with
XX or x y what does that mean
I have X Y chromosomes if my DNA is
found at the scene of a crime not saying
it will but you know we'll see
if my skeleton is discovered thousands
of years from now
I'll be labeled male
is that the truth
my balls would say so
but what about the rest of me
and what if a woman has ovarian cancer
and has to have her ovaries removed does
she still qualify as a woman
heard about other intersex people who
are born without balls or ovaries or
with just one or a combination of the
two where do they go
do you have to have a uterus to be a
woman there's a lot of us are born
without one
and everyone's favorite part genitalia
you either have one or the other right
you either have a six inch long penis
that's exactly this thick jutting
straight out of the body at a 90 degree
angle or you have a vagina that's
Justified internally and a clitoris
that's half an inch above the vaginal
opening and labia that look exactly like
they're supposed to look like according
to that one porn video you watched that
one time you know the one
if you've been with more than one sexual
partner in your lifetime and you line
them up one by one I guarantee you could
identify them just by their genitalia
think about it
go on yeah oh yeah I see you no judging
just notice all different right
the sex and gender binary are both so
ingrained in our society that we never
stop to think about it we just
automatically place each other into one
box or the other as if
it actually matters until somebody comes
along to make you question it
and if you're thinking that I'm the
exception an anomaly an outlier
intersex people represent around two
percent of the population
that's the same percentage as genetic
redheads
it's about 150 million people roughly
which is more than the entire population
of Russia
so there's a lot of us needless to say
we're not new we're rare
we're just invisible
we've existed throughout every culture
in history yet we never talk about it
in fact a lot of people might not know
that they're intersex
have you had a karyotype test to
determine your chromosomes
what about a full blood panel for all of
your hormone levels
a friend of mine found out last year in
his 50s
the executive director of interact which
is the leading Organization for intersex
human rights here in the U.S
she found out she was intersex at age
41.
her doctors found out when she was 15.
but they didn't tell her
they lied and said that she had cancer
because that seemed like an easier
option than finding out she wasn't fully
a woman
this kind of thing happens a lot where
intersex people are lied to or kept in
the dark about our bodies which comes as
a surprise to a lot of people but we
live in a society that doesn't talk
about sex or bodies at all unless it's
to mock or shame each other
I found out I was intersex at age 10 and
for the most part I was fine with that
information it didn't really phase me I
was still developing my understanding of
the world
and it wasn't until I got older and
realized that I didn't fit society's
expectations of me that I didn't belong
that I was abnormal
and that's when the shame started
how many times have you seen kids play
with the wrong toys for their gender
we're trying the wrong clothes
all the time right
kids don't have these ideas about gender
Norm they don't have Shame about who
they're supposed to be or what they're
supposed to like or love
we don't care about any of this stuff
they don't have shame until we put it on
them
I also had doctors lie to me at age 10
they told me that I would also get
cancer unless I removed my balls then
they proceeded to tell me that every
year
until today there's still doctors who
want me to remove them
but there's literally no reason
if a typical XY male like yourself has
testicles and one is undescended
there's a high chance of it becoming
cancerous or a higher chance of it
becoming cancerous they need to be
thermoregulated so they drop down away
from the body
to cool off or they shrink back up to
get warm mine don't need to do that
they're not responding to testosterone
they're not producing sperm they're fine
right here inside my body
yet because there's such a lack of
information about intersex people my
doctors never understood the difference
they never really understood my body
as I got older I had another doctor tell
me that I needed to have surgery on my
vagina
she said that until I had an operation
until she operated I would not be able
to have normal sex with my husband one
day her words
and didn't end up going through with the
operation and I'm incredibly grateful
for that
that's I'm not here to talk about my sex
life
let's just say it's fine
um I'm fine my body is fine you actually
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
between me and another person unless I
told you you wouldn't be able to tell
that I was intersex unless I told you
but again because of the lack of
understanding about bodies my doctor
didn't understand the difference
and for the most part my sex life is
fine
the only issue that really comes up is
that sometimes sexual situations bring
up memories of doctors touching me over
and over again since I was 10.
I've been really lucky to escape
I didn't think I would get emotional
I've been really lucky to escape the
physical harm that comes from these
unnecessary surgeries
but no intersex person is free from the
emotional harm
that comes from living in a society that
tries to cover up your existence
most of my intersex friends have had
operations like these
oftentimes they will remove testes like
mine even though
my risk of testicular cancer is lower
than the risk of breast cancer in a
typical woman with no predisposition no
family history
but we don't tell her to remove her
breasts do we
it's rare to meet an intersex person
that hasn't been operated on
and
oftentimes these surgeries are done to
improve intersex kids lives
but they usually end up doing the
opposite causing more harm and
complications both physical and
emotional
I'm not saying that doctors are bad or
evil it's just that we live in a society
that causes some doctors to fix those of
us who don't fit their definition of
normal
we're not problems that need to be fixed
we just live in a society that needs to
be enlightened
one of the ways I'm doing that is by
creating a genderless puberty guide book
that can teach kids about their bodies
as they grow up not their girl bodies or
their boy bodies just their bodies we
often Place unrealistic expectations on
the things that our bodies do better
outside of our control
I mean if one man can grow a full
luxurious hipster beard and the other
can only grow a few mustache hairs what
does that mean about who they are as men
nothing
it literally most likely just means that
their hair follicles respond to
testosterone in different ways
yet how many of times have you heard a
man ashamed about something like this
imagine a world where we could live in a
society that teaches us not to have
Shame about the things that our bodies
do or do not do
I want to change the way that we think
about biological sex in this Society
which is a lot to ask for
say it's ballsy I guess
[Laughter]
but eventually we accepted the world as
round right we no longer diagnose gay
people with mental disorders or women
with Hysteria
we don't think epilepsy is caused by the
devil anymore so that's cool
we constantly change and evolve the more
we understand as a society
and biological sex is on a spectrum it's
not black or white
not only could that knowledge save
intersex kids from physical and
emotional harm I think it would help
everyone else too
who here has ever felt inadequate or
ashamed because you weren't girly enough
you were too girly you weren't manly
enough or too manly
we constantly shame people for not
fitting into a box but the reality is I
think we'd shame others because it
prevents them from seeing that we don't
fit inside our boxes either
and the truth is that nobody actually
fits in a box because they don't exist
this binary this false male female
facade is something we constructed we
built ourselves but it doesn't have to
exist
we can break it down
and that's what I want to do
will you join me
[Applause]
[Music]